good day everyone and welcome i'm jack van horn
from the university of virginia and once again
please allow me to welcome you to this edition
of our 2020 2021 foundations of biomedical data
science seminar series this lecture series is
supported by uva's integrated translational health
institute of virginia the uva brain institute
the college of arts and sciences the school
of data science and through a grant from the
national institutes of general medical sciences
it is my honor and privilege to welcome our
speaker today dr randy gollub from the macans
center for brain health at massachusetts
general hospital in boston massachusetts
dr gollub earned her phd and her md from duke
university school of medicine she conducted a
residency at the hospital in san rafael in new
haven connecticut and her another residency
at yale new haven hospital and she has um board
certifications in psychiatry as well as through
the american board of psychiatry and neurology
dr gollub was recently elected to the chair of
the organization for human brain mapping
and serves as professor of psychiatry and
associate director of translational research and
neuroimaging research program at massachusetts
general hospital she is a recognized leader in
the development and applications of advanced
neuroimaging technologies to understand the
pathophysiology of neuropsychiatric disorders
including neonatal hypox hypoxic ischemic
encephalopathy chronic pain and schizophrenia
she is actively working on translating
these advances into clinical radiological
practice to improve patient care the use of
large-scale imaging informatics approaches
work in her laboratory focuses on using clinically
acquired brain images from neonatal subjects as
well as young children to build age-specific
normative brain atlases of quantitative
tissue metrics to advance understanding
of brain development in the application of
those normative atlases to detect abnormalities
associated with hypoxic ischemic encephalopathy
and neonates this approach enables the detection
of subtle anatomical variations through the
use of machine learning algorithms and other
sophisticated statistical techniques the work of
dr gollub and her team demonstrates the exciting
potential of leveraging existing electronic health
records data including clinically acquired brain
imaging scans to yield information on par with
clinical research studies that were conducted
over decades at the cost of many million dollars
dr gollub's lecture today is entitled clinical
imaging informatics in action extracting valuable
knowledge from archival pediatric brain mri and
as always we are streaming this lecture live and
for recording via youtube if you are joining us by
youtube thank you so much for your attention today
also specifically selected 2020 2021 biomedical
data science innovation lab participants
are encouraged to submit any questions for dr
gollub by the chat feature in their zoom sessions
i will synthesize these questions and i'll ask
them on your behalf during the last 10 minutes
or so of the lecture and with that welcome randy
we are so excited to hear your lecture today
well thank you jack for that lovely and
friendly introduction and good afternoon
everyone um or whatever time you're watching this
uh it is my pleasure to be here and to share this
um fairly unique kind of research with you all
i know for those of you who are in this program
some of you are trained as clinicians and certain
features of this will be a little bit more
familiar and others not so i'll hopefully take
the time to help everyone be on the same playing
field to understand how this is done and why um in
particular i'm i'm going to try and make the case
in a way that will be completely understandable
as to why someone would want to bother to use the
clinical imaging data that's collected
for secondary research purposes
i'm going to help you to understand what the
challenges are and also show you some exciting
new developments that are beginning to overcome
some of those challenges i'm going to show you
at our institution how exactly we can make this
happen and then by way of sharing the exemplar
work that's being done with my colleagues help
you to have a real intuitive understanding of
what could be done and its potential with a you
know just a glimpse at what the future might hold
i just want to take this moment to give a shout
out to my friend and colleague steve piper who
if you notice in this little front picture here
each of these this sweet baby's face is made up
of a mosaic of these little thumbnails of brain
image data this is a sort of a very dramatic
illustration of how much of those image data we
have available to us to use to do this research
and steve is a master of these things so i the
why part the why part is really important um
why bother you know you've heard recent talks
i believe jessica turner spoke with you not too
long ago about the enigma all these different
uh huge efforts that are being underway that
are being funded to collect lots and lots
of data for the research community to use
well there's other data also and there are special
reasons why this data might be more appropriate
for something that you're interested in doing so
for example if you quickly need to get a hold of
say 200 000 brain mri scans that you wanted to be
able to extract a hippocampal volume from in order
to build an ai tool that would help you to screen
for early evidence of cognitive decline well
this path that i'm going to show you might
be one you know it's not free and it's not
you know immediate but there is a path to get that
data to work on and in particular because this
is real world collected in the wild data the tool
that you would develop using these scans might be
more much more immediately useful to run on the
standard clinical scanners that are in use in
the different academic health care centers
or hospitals you know worldwide and and as
opposed to tools many of which get developed
on the research data um and those early passes
really have limitations to how
well they will operate on this
uh tougher data i should say i'll be
showing you some things about that today
another really important um thing to consider is
what kind of data from which patient cohort or
what kind of ages are necessary for the work you
want to do and in in some cases if it's a rare
disease it may be very hard over the time scale
that you might have available on a grant or a
you know in your lifespan to collect
everything on yourself so there's
collaborations but there's also ways of acquiring
that data through the hospital archival scans
and in the case of what i'll show you today it's
that rare data from being able to get a hold of
information from brand new babies who typically
are not in a hospital having a brain scan
and while i'll talk today about all brain
mri because that's the domain that i work in
um in fact this workflow this sort of conceptual
frame for what i'm showing you would be
completely appropriate if you needed a ct
scan if you needed an ultrasound if you
whatever kind of imaging that you needed to use
the workflow that this data comes in under is an
important concept uh to understand in terms of
what you know you can think of it as your your
experiment of how you're enrolling your
patients you'll see how this matters
in the typical clinical workflow a scan would be
collected because some doctor has a patient that
they feel needs to have some imaging done to help
them care for their patient they enter an order
a unique accession number is assigned to that to
identify the study in the patient it's scheduled
this protocol step is really important that's
where the radiology department or the other
domain expert will choose explicitly how the
the scan will be collected always it's done
in with respect to what is the question being
asked of that patient when the patient arrives
they are brought to the scanner that information
is used to um to label the scan and during
the scan session if the operator notices knew
something that they weren't expecting they might
add or change that protocol by adding additional
scans or if there's a problem in the system they
might repeat a scan and then those images
are are passed to this archival storage the
picture archive and communication system the
pax which is a very smart database because it
supports a lot of communications all the images
are in a file format called dicom those of you
who work with any kind of medical images aren't
probably familiar with this standard it's whole
lectures on these topics right here and depending
on the study they may already be automatically
best done based on the order that was entered in
the exam that was done sent for some additional
advanced image processing to feed that information
also back into the packs and then it's fed into
the workflow of the radiologists who will read
that information read the scans interpret them and
fill out a report that is then also put into the
medical record and so people working in ehr data
have access to many of these different bits
they uh accept these images typically when a
when a clinical informatics person is working
with medical imaging data what they're really
working with is doing some nlp on the exam um
that the interpretation that the radiologist
has provided and not digging very deeply
into the medical image data itself
so one i wanted to share a force vector
that suggests that this work could be very
meaningful and continue to be more impactful
over time as the fields of research imaging and
clinical imaging they're always interacting with
each other as the quality of the scans improves
through higher temporal resolution and spatial
resolution and different types of sequences that
give more and more information that's meaningful
about tissue properties the um the size the
magnitude the amount of data that's embedded in a
scan it continues to grow and so the requirement
to extract as much information out of that also
continues to grow and so this move towards more
quantitative assessments with tools that mine
the data and and then use the information as it's
coming in to help create more useful information
for how to care for a patient builds on this
informatics infrastructure and so the whole
field is definitely moving stronger and in many
supported ways towards this more quantitative
extraction of meaningful data out of the medical
images which supports the effort that we're doing
because it may kind of makes it easier to find and
work with and do more with that data and makes
the results that we create on the research side
gives us a tighter and stronger loop back
up into the clinical into clinical care
so just a quick digression just to say that
the these standardized radiology reports this
templated reporting is also something that
is of value in that it helps that when a ai
tool quantifying hippocampal volume happens that
the radiologist has a way to easily and quickly
in insert that information into the medical
record making the ehr data more and more rich
and easier and easier to use for research but also
enhances the quality of what is is available for
the clinicians in those radiology reports when
they're making their decisions for patient care
and so the incorporation of that additional
information is eased through these structured
reporting so all these different efforts on
these different fronts kind of are all sort of
lifting um lifting us up and making it more and
more likely and more reasonable that this work
will have a clinical impact and in the end that's
what matters um so much so so now coming back from
our digression so the unique challenges if you
want to use this kind of data for your research
um if we look at the parallels in this domain you
know you might be used to in the research world
thinking about designing a study where you would
uh have a standardized acquisition protocol
you'd be very specific about it and all the
little details of how it would be how a brain
mri scan might be collected would be decided in
advance you'd have maybe make efforts to send
a human phantom to the different sites to make
sure that they were all calibrated as perfectly
as you could you go for the best possible image
resolution you carefully screen your subjects
if you have a patient cohort you use
detailed inclusion exclusion criteria
to select them you carefully match the healthy
subjects on all the different demographics that
would need to be give you the best bang for the
buck and carefully comparing your patients to
controls the results you get very quantitative and
standardized so when we go through a clinical on
the clinical side we approach it very differently
because as i just taught you for every time
an acquisition happens it's really patient-centric
it's based on the needs of the patient and
customized to them and so you know while there is
some systematic um effort in there because there
are just a sort of a finite number of protocols
and sequences that could be run the recipe is
uh you know absolutely tweaked per person and the
and an important issue here is time versus money
so the uh the more that you more resolution
the higher the resolution the more detail the
more complete the net anatomical coverage all of
those things map to taking longer time not only
to acquire but for the radiologists to read and
interpret and so the data sets as they're acquired
clinically are matched to the clinical question
if a person has just been ruled out for a stroke
they're going to get a very fast very rough scan
because strokes show up really well on these scans
and so the minutes that you might take to get
a better answer will be potentially lost brain
or date more brain damage when the real need is
to get the person quickly into the suite where
better imaging is available but they'll have it as
they are already doing an intervention to save the
quality to save that person's brain by opening a
clot or stopping a hemorrhage or whatever they're
doing and so the variability in the quality of
the scans is quite high depending on the question
being asked if you're going in for a pre-surgical
mapping for a epilepsy problem you might have
super high resolution because they're looking for
these tiny little cortical dysplasias for example
so on the subject level very rarely is any data
normal because no one is getting scanned because
they're normal they're not they're getting scanned
because they're trying to rule out a problem
but sometimes there aren't problems and it's very
reassuring to the patient and the clinician that
they didn't find the problem and they look for
something else in a different way and so some
of the there are a few scans in the packs that are
healthy and not and and don't have brain pathology
and what you get out are those radiology reports
which are just a mere fragment of a fraction of
what's available in the data so when i here's
a few just representative you know images
randomly pulled out from our study just to show
you that the quality of the data that's in there
is really quite nice and um and there's lots of
it and all different kinds of it and it's awesome
um but not all of it so more often
than in a research study there will
be poor quality because of under sampling
or motion or some kind of a noise artifact
and i'm going to do it again on one of my
little digressions here to just show you
um right now the way that we deal with this is
we just have to exclude these studies because we
can't use them but there are some really exciting
novel approaches that are on the horizon to
mitigate this damage or correct them afterwards
and work that's being done partly by some of the
students and faculty where i work and and many
other places i think probably around the world
but i'm going to teach you one tiny bit
about mr physics which is just to say that um
that this work that's being done by my uh but our
student nalini singh it's a really cool work um
relies on the fact that in an at the time
that a patient is in the scanner or the
scan data is being collected it's collected in
what's called frequency space or k space and
a fourier transform is done to take the data out
of k space and generate the image in a typical mr
workflow this happens with one pass it's done and
then that's what gets loaded into the radiology
archives so here is an experiment that she
has been working on where she's actually
using some machine learning tools to use both
the k-space and the image space data together
using a a deep learning joint algorithm that takes
those two inputs the k-space image and the image
the k-space and the reconstructed image
and uses them to iteratively improve the
quality of the out the final image that would
be put into the radiology archives for example
so what i'm showing you here in the data set she
uses for the for this research she has what is
called ground truth which is a very high quality
beautiful scan here down here at the bottom row
you see the frequency spectrum that's the k
space that would have come off the scanner in
the little red box is a a higher resolution and
not a higher but blow focus in on this blood box
is what's shown in this little patch right here
so you can see more of the anatomical detail
and when she takes the data set from the same
subject that's been corrupted by this motion
the person was moving their head up and down
you can see that in you know especially easy
to see in this higher field um image that there
is a lot of a lot a ton of loss of information
this difference line here shows you the difference
between what's in the high resolution ground truth
and this input image here's what the case
space looks like in that corrupted image
so after it goes through her magic i'm not
even showing you the black box this empty
white space is her algorithm what it spits out is
an image that looks very close to the ground truth
you can see it higher resolution here and in the
difference image you can see it's not perfect it's
not exact but it is considerably better than
what you see in in the original image and so
this is you know future state because this would
have to be done at the scanner when you saw the k
space available uh the case-based data available
in a standard workflow once it's once the
four-year transform happens images are saved the
case-based data is thrown away and so you can't
work backwards it's super cool work and uh there's
a citation if you want to learn more about it
um similarly uh some of my other colleagues
this is work led by eugenio igrisius he takes a
post-acquisition approach and in this case
it has the possibility of actually
rescuing scans that were collected
um enabling us to do more quantitative morphometry
on that data or morphometric analyses on that data
and this is maybe a little closer on the horizon
because we can use it on existing scan so again
this is work that requires the training
of these deep convolutional neural nets
where inputs they train a model using good quality
data and generate models but then taking these
these poor poor resolution or noisier scans as i'm
showing you here as the inputs into that trained
algorithm can output something that is a little
bit closer actually considerably closer to what um
ground truth would be and this work is being done
on a data set that is adney dataset so he has both
ground truth and uh and the degraded images to
work with um to make this a little more concrete
um here's what a scan this is a an axial scan
through the brain and it's showing you the output
of the software tool called free surfer which
is able to both segment cortical and subcortical
structures but also make a very high resolution
assessment of the cortical surface and the peel
surface and generate these nice surface maps where
you can see cortical thickness and curvatures and
things like that um in data that's collected on
say a more typical clinical acquisition would
be thicker slices so this might um might be
seven millimeters instead of one millimeter in
thickness here the algorithm doesn't do
the pre-surfer tool does not work so well
but after he runs his um his convolutional neural
network on that data and spits it out it does
bring it right back much closer to what the
original what he the known ground truth in
this case this research dataset shows and so here
quantitatively with respect to that hippocampal
volume i was speaking of before when you look
at the how accurate the reconstructed data is
or a lower resolution data is and how accurately
it can find hippocampal volumes what he has been
able to show is that with his nice algorithm the
amount of error goes from in a seven millimeter
scan goes from the scattergram of these red dots
to this scattergram with the blue dots making
the average error dropping from ten percent to
three percent and increasing the effect size
the result you're basically that what that
means is you have a much greater sensitivity
to detect an abnormality that is due to the
true anatomy anatomical problem and so while
this has been done on one test data set this is
again also a recent report so early days lots of
exciting to look forward with that okay back from
those digressions about cool tools that are going
to help this and help us in the future let me show
you how how we do this at my institution and so
um we have at so i don't know how many of you
at your centers have a clinical informatics
infrastructure maybe you have the one called
itb2 or some other ones where you're able to
do a lot of research using the uh the nicely
archived clinical data where we where i work
this is called partners now it's we call it mgb
for mass general brigham we have a really robust
set of tools where we can actually find patient
cohorts and work that i've done collaboratively
with my colleagues in radiology and this group's
team as well as dan marcus at washu we designed
and built a module plug-in to it that allows us
to actually pull those medical image data out
so reminding you of this slide i showed you a
little earlier um the rpdr tool is things you
know allows us to pull out these demographics
about the patient and their accession numbers
and the radiology report and the medical record
numbers and all that stuff whereas the metoo b2
tool allows us to actually go in and query and
retrieve from the packs the actual image data
so how does it work um you are credentialed
in here's my colleague sean who is the my
co-developer in arms for developing this
capability he is the the visionary behind
this whole our pdr infrastructure here but the um
this is a basically a query front end for a big
database a huge database with something like six
or seven million patients worth of records in it
and you know i don't know how many hundreds of
millions of pieces of information it sits in
front of but you basically just click on little
folders uh that represent the information you're
interested in to drag over and submit a query
that is the equivalent to you designing your
cohort experiment so you can choose a cohort based
on a diagnosis a set of diagnostic codes or on a
set of procedure codes or lab values you can
include or exclude them you can restrict by
age groups you can do all sorts of very very
sophisticated analysis analyses to generate a
query and you don't even need an irb at this point
what you're doing is just trying to understand
how many what the sample size is that would meet
your criteria and you know kind of does it break
out demographically to be what you want because
once you've jet you generate the query that
represents the cohort you're interested in you
click this request detailed button detail data
button and actually that was an older slide
an older version now we actually so that's
this is the same slide i that i had just showed
you but now in our our newer more enhanced version
the in addition to requesting the detailed data
which would just be when i told you rpdr splits
out we have another button that says request those
uh this is how you get your me to b2 workbench
that stands for medical imaging informatics
bench to bedside me too me too i want my
images is how i named that thing um so this is
where you uh you click this button in order to
put in your request for the brain imaging data so
this tool works really nicely because you know if
you are getting your images because of a query it
works just fine but let's just say that you have
an ongoing collaboration with a set of research
colleagues who already know things about your
studies so for example in the work i'll be showing
you shortly some of my neuroradiology colleagues
have been curating lists of healthy normal babies
and and children because they needed them for
teaching cases to teach the radiology residents
so when they would come across that rare once in a
while person who actually had a child or maybe who
had a healthy uh who turned out to be healthy and
not have anything bad happen like an example of um
somebody who a baby who had accidentally fallen in
a swimming pool and and and was lifted out and
they were worried that you know they might have
not um might have hurt themselves might have been
scanned and then we had years of follow-up to say
they were fine for example that would be the kind
of thing that we might find um we had that list uh
we had a list of cases we got that way so you
can put that list in also and then you put in
a request for your me to b2 workbench and what's
really important about how we built this is that
um access to both the rpdr data and the me
to be to image acquired images is through
um is managed in a way that's hipaa compliant in
order to keep a log at all times of under what irb
by what which investigators accessed which data
sets and they're all audit logged and we keep
track of all of that information to be able to
report out once the person has their workbench
they log in and through a series of steps they
find the they sort of have to fine-tune here's
where searching in the radiology data there's
a little bit of work to be done there to find
the actual sequences and the studies that you want
and you transfer those out for you to work with um
there's citation right here teaches you
all about how we built this me2b2 workflow
and actually uh has the link to it's an open open
source code um so on the uh itube b2 wiki and the
community pages there's actually a project for us
and so any of your sites that have i2b2 that you
might would like to use this kind of software
you can it isn't we are already updating it um
locally so if you have any questions reach out to
me and i will happily talk to you more about it if
you're interested in knowing how to use this tool
and what it takes and how to do it there's really
detailed tutorials on our help page which is open
this is not behind our firewall anybody can see it
and we'll walk you through exactly how how
you use this tool to pull your data down
so that was the how you get to
the data but now let me show you
some of the studies that we have done with some of
this data that we began working on in about 2015
as we were pulling the data down maybe even a
little bit before that and then even more recently
and this is really work that could only be done
with the vision of my colleague ellen grant who
sort of saw this whole arc of what i'm about to
share with you um in her mind's eye and it's been
a real pleasure being on this ride with her and
a lot of the work has been done by yang ming ooh
um uh i'll show you more as we go okay so for this
and and this is work that you will be able to find
at that reference but i just showed you how you
can use the rpdr tool to query and find scans
and so we used a combination of the query tool as
well as our data list and we identified about 2871
scans where we knew that they had had a brain mri
scan done and we knew that they were between the
ages of zero and six years of age at the time
the scan was done the brain number eye was done
now one of the tricks here was that because ellen
is a neuroradiologist extraordinaire she was the
one who had actually set up the protocols for all
baby brain mri and she had included a particular
sequence and we knew that one of the other
criteria we used this the scan had been collected
after i think 2006 because that's when um she
very much before others were using diffusion
rated imaging she was one of the pioneers of
it she got the protocol set up and run um and
perfected so that it did the best possible job
and where a single protocol would actually work
nicely across the ages of zero to six and so over
the many years since the only only very minor
changes to that protocol happened like when they
would upgrade a scanner or the scanner software
but the basic procedure was continued all through
those years and so we had a very coherent co
data set to begin with so we imported those
scans from the packs to our local workstation
and then because we didn't have any tools
that would help us get rid of the corruption
that i was showing you or other kinds of you
know loss because of the data we lost only
in this case it's about not quite 50 of the data
which is an incredibly small loss most other
studies that you might be going after to get good
data you'd have a much higher loss at this point
but we had a very good throughput because we knew
how to ask the right question of the data that
was available so collaborating with your local
neuroradiologist is really key okay so then once
we had gotten all of those scans we um we had
clinician scientists and nurse practitioners
reviewing uh not and then our imaging scientists
reviewing both the adc scans themselves those are
quantitative apparent diffusion coefficient scans
and also looking into the ehr we have under our
irb we had permission to not only download the
data but to go into the medical records to be
able to see finer details because our pdr doesn't
have every detail of every patient in it and some
of the details you need to look in this pediatric
data set um we had to look up on our own and we
used the redcap database to collect all that kind
of information in and after carefully reviewing
um we got we had to screen out um in this case
we're looking just for the healthy normative ones
we uh screened down to about 705 potential cases
that that might work well for us and then um
again through the uh the this was just looking
to make sure that the scans were normal enough
and then we had to do additional
medical chart review on those cases
to confirm that for several years afterwards
a minimum of three years that the patients did
not develop any neuropsychiatric abnormalities to
make sure that the image data that we were calling
normative was indeed reasonably representative
of normal brain functions and structure and that
got us down from 705 to 201 no again surprise that
people who are imaged are imaged for a reason for
clinical reasons that are you know where you are
interested in finding out or you have a clinical
uh clinical suspicion that there is something
wrong with the brain and even though at this
point the radiology reports were read as normal
or normative that meant that the radiologists
on their own could not detect abnormalities
it doesn't mean that they weren't there
it just means that this particular study did
not reveal it it was not sensitive to reveal it
and that's really you know sort of a heads up
i'll come back to that um way that is telling you
something so if you're losing 500 scans because
people do end up having abnormalities that you
can tell already by the ages of three years old
then maybe there is some signal there that isn't
being captured and it's a commercial for what
i'm going to tell you in a few more minutes
so getting down to the 210 we
finally have nice clean data
that we can use to generate some atlases
which i'm going to tell you about again
right now and and use those in various ways
to help us help the clinicians do better
make better use of this data so the question is
how do you generate the once we generate those
addlesses how do we do good work with them and
use them in ways that are really meaningful and so
when a research scientist on their own would
go out and want to think about how do i
generate these different brain atlases across
these different ages they might recruit a patient
in and study them repeatedly over over the periods
of time so you could have longitudinal data which
gives you the most sensitivity to detect change
over time but then you're limited by your cohort
size and you can only generalize to people like
the ones that you scanned um if you're interested
in the span that goes from zero years of age to
six years of age also the obstacle of scanning
repeatedly in that age age over that age span is
is very challenging there are some good data sets
out there and people working very nicely with
them but the approach that this data allows us
to do is a very different one where across time
we aggregate clusters of patients again no two
patients were used one of the reasons another
reason that the numbers dropped as i was showing
you in the in the previous seating slide is
sometimes there were repeat images on the
same subject so they might have been studied on
being studied longitudinally for clinical reasons
but we only use them once in our data so that we
didn't have any biases and so every single age we
have a cohort of patients that are the same age
and we can generate what an average what a mean
is of a different group each different time the
value of this is that first of all it's feasible
you can do it and and the costs of uh you save
a lot of money not having to recruit and scan
and you're also getting a better exemplar of what
an average population might look like so i'm going
to spend a minute on this slide just to say this
was something we actually were able to do in the
early days some of our very first efforts with
this data this is probably back in like 2014 maybe
where every one of these circles is a different
scan result from a different individual baby
or child this is the data platter
from the first about 800 days of life
so very early on and where there's
colored markers and lines those are
cases where an individual actually
had that longitudinal imaging going on
and a couple things i want to illustrate here so
we had to be able to skull strip and and somewhat
normalize the data to be able to do this and
also um you know strip away the csf so that
we could get what is called a whole brain adc
map so this is averaging across all the voxels
in the brain the whole brain and this wba whole
brain adc measure and what's plotted what you see
is how in the very earliest days it's high
and then it starts to come down lower which
you can sort of appreciate here in that it's
brighter and getting darker one of the key things
to notice is that this signal intensity is not
the adc is not homogeneous over the whole brain
um it does vary anatomically and so the spatial
localization of the value is really important
and what um when we were first gathering this
the the first uh effort ellen had told me she
was interested she said we should be able to
find in this data a gradient from posterior
to anterior because this drop happens earlier in
the back of the brain than the front of the brain
one of the features that makes this data so hard
for clinicians to read and interpret is that these
changes are happening so rapidly especially in
these early days of life so interpreting what
is normal healthy changes due to aging and
what changes are due to a pathological event
is really hard to interpret and that is part of
the motivation for the work that we are doing
so i mentioned that i'd show you a little
bit more about how those atlases are created
so taking those 201 total uh data sets we divided
them bend them into age bins the first two weeks
of life uh the second through fourth second
quarter third quarter fourth quarter year two
three four five six and uh in each of those uh
uh cohorts there were enough cases that we could
um here here are all the 13 case the 13 different
babies that were used for the youngest age atlas
they were skull stripped and put into register
and signal normalized and then an atlas was
generated that generated the mean uh adc at
every single voxel as well as a set of standard
deviation measures and here are those atlases
this this is the one for right here the mean
uh this is just showing the mean of the adc
values over the brain in the coronal sagittal
and axial views and this is for each one of those
different atlases from one to two weeks up through
year six the way it's windowed here it's a
little hard to appreciate the subtle differences
but i what i will tell you is that when
we published this paper um it contributed
tremendously to the literature because many people
have been trying to gather this data and there
were bits and pieces in the literature reported
here and there but ours was the most comprehensive
that covered this whole time frame um i'm gonna
do my normal uh my well-deserved pitch to my
colleagues who make this this resource available
that hosts the nitric website which is a wonderful
neuroimaging resource for finding all tools
all software all data sets go there if you
need anything to do with brain imaging if you
don't know about it you should know about it
everybody should know about it but this is where
our yin ning posted the software for how to make
an atlas like this and this is where those atlases
are actually released in case you want them
and here's the most recent work it took until just
this past year to get published uh so at first
this is hard and second radial neuroradiologists
are really busy but i want to call your attention
to the fact that this is actually published um in
the journal radiology this is the journal that the
radiologists use to help them advance their
clinical practice and what they by actually
getting our study into that journal which
actually came with a a really nice um a uh
an editorial that said not something about not
for the faint of heart because they appreciated
how much work was done to be able to uh quantify
this information like not everybody can do this
be careful um but i want you guys to know that
you can do this uh and that and that this is a
really valuable contribution to make and so um by
getting it into this audience we are able to show
uh on both a sort of region by region uh way and
also voxel by a box we'll show you in a minute on
how the brain matures over this age range and to
provide some quantitative metrics for what that
looks like in these adc maps that radiologists
can use to help them benchmark their reads and
so here are those atlases that i had just shown
you and here are these beautiful segmentations
which yangming was able to make happen because he
he was able to use these these atlas transforms to
bring a segmentation atlas into this space
and transform it into younger younger ages
typically these atlases require way more
sort of detail in the primary image data
to be able to find these anatomical features and
these adc maps they're very blurry it's tough to
see this kind of detail and so having a tool that
is meaningfully segmenting these multiple regions
is incredibly useful because it allows you to do
something like this which is to plot region by
region how the adc changes over age where let me
walk you through this set of histograms over here
what you see here is plotted these
are the adc values so you can
this is flipped axis from what i was showing
you on the plot my very first one where i was
showing that little bit of longitudinal data in
our and our and our cohort but here is plotted
the percentage of voxels in a particular roi um
the roi here the region of interest here is the
whole brain so this is like that same whole brain
histogram and um and now it's broken out across
the ages so starting at two you know the the
youngest uh this is these are the highest values
so you can see this is sort of like watching the
the the data come down in that histogram here
in that in that plot that i showed you now you're
seeing the histogram move towards these lower and
lower values but you're also seeing something
really interesting it's not completely smooth
and you're starting to see some little bumps here
which tell you that there may be different some
hint of that anatomical variability about when
different structures mature and so that's what's
in these other plots here so each of these numbers
corresponds to one of these different plots
and each of those numbers is a different brain
region and what you're but again we're showing
the changes in um at each of the different ages
over time and you can appreciate those which show
a slower rate of of maturation along the scale
compared to those that show a much steeper change
and so this kind of information is quantitatively
useful to a radiologist as they are moving around
in the space and trying to get a grip on
what they should expect to see in their data
here's a kind of a prettier way to look at this
with 3d mapping of the same data um where what
you're looking at is sort of the evolution of
how this changes and finally with a with a lot of
really elegant uh image processing capabilities we
can actually visualize that occipital to frontal
wave of maturation that's seen in this
uh in this adc signal chain adc signal um
so just really lovely so let me just i only
have a little bit more time let me show you
um another clinical application
of this work um so this
when babies are born who have had basically a
normal pregnancy everything is great and fine
something happens right around the time of birth
and a full-term infant is born where there for uh
there are many many this is a this is kind of a
grab bag term for what are many many different
reasons why a baby might not have enough oxygen
or blood to their brain which causes brain damage
it sadly occurs relatively often and now we're
starting to have much better treatments for
example they figured out that they put the little
baby in a cooling they cool the baby's temperature
slightly put them in these little cooling caps
they can slow down metabolism they can slow down
um the damage that's occurring and help the
baby to recover and and save a lot of brain but
when this happens it's not uncommon for there
to be long-term outcome um problems uh neuro
deficits of many different kinds and so when the
clinicians are and parents are trying to decide
on the best possible care for a baby and for them
you know for their family one of the tools that
they use to understand what's going on is to get
one of those brain mris just like i showed you
and it's part of clinical it's clinically
required and again they are using those
exact same acquisitions that i showed you
those really good quality acquisitions
that have been stable and not just at our site but
across the country and the world it is standard
that they use these these brain mris to help
predict outcome long-term outcomes and there is
some amount of agreement but and it does
help and they do contribute and use the data
but there's a lot of variability both within a
single reader like the same clinician reading
the same study you give it to them on other
days and other times they may not even get the
same answer out but very much between raters
or different experts and so even when people
have a lot of experience doing this it's hard for
them to read these cases um consistently and so
what you know i've now taught you about those
adc maps and uh in hie the hypoxic ischemic
encephalopathy the the damage shows up as lower
adc values okay and so sometimes it's really
easy to see and in this case this is a healthy
example um age match to this clinical example
and probably all of you can make out easily
those lesions that are that you know that are
not tough to to read where there's damage there
are most cases are far more challenging than that
and if i asked you to show me where on this
scan or on this scan there were abnormalities
it's a much tougher tougher job and so how do
we do that we can take our atlases and so here
you know is that adc atlas from those
little babies from zero to two weeks of age
and here is one of those scans from a baby with
a patient who has been diagnosed with hie when we
those voxels and your eye can probably make out um
i'm seeing a thing that says my internet's
unstable hopefully you can still hear me okay
maybe your eye can make out this darker area
here and maybe your eye can make out somewhat
this little darker areas here and here maybe
you weren't as able to appreciate some of these
areas that were brighter than they than
they they might be expected to be and so
um we're doing the work now to um to map how
carefully and how accurately these uh this
this algorithm might by the algorithm being taking
the atlas and comparing it to the um to the norm
to the patient's own scan how often our atlases
will detect the same thing that a radiologist
here two different radiologists manually marked
up this patient's adc map and here you can see
how closely the algorithm will compare to that so
this is one line of work that's going on right now
another way that we can use this is to generate
atlases from the scans of the babies who have the
abnormalities and get some sense of information
about which are the most commonly found areas that
are abnormal and or which regions and or networks
of regions are important for yielding the kinds of
clinical pathology that we see so finally just
a quick sort of vision of what a futures future
positive might look like if this work continues
or things like it then when the radiologist is
in a radiate in the reading room and they have a
patient's data they're looking at what they might
also pull up in front of them would be a reference
atlas that would tell them so they could mouse
over the two different ones and get a sense of
what values should be there and what do i actually
have here if i think i see something abnormal and
also potentially even a beautifully color-coded
map that shows them where to double check more
carefully and it's still their choice what to make
of this and whether that is information that's
useful or not and they have a lot more information
they use it's not to replace the radiologist
this the name for this is computer aided
diagnosis you give the you use computational tools
to help the clinicians to um to do their work and
so that's the kind of thing we're hoping to see
but maybe even before that that it would be useful
in classrooms for teaching people so i will pause
there for more questions i will just i give a
huge shout out to ellen and to yang ming my friend
steve the fabulous team that makes the um our our
informatics tools work and sing at home there's
lots more people and and good funding and i'm
really blessed to have had great uh trainees that
worked with me from epfl and i missed them i wish
they were still back in my lab it's a great team
and uh thank you for your time and for listening
randy thank you so much for that that was uh
really uh exciting to see all that neural imaging
work and some of those studies are yeah absolutely
not for the faint of heart that's a lot of work
um i have a few questions for you um this goes
back to the earlier part of your talk where you're
talking about some of the uh uh image quality
variation that we see in kind of clinical studies
and i'm curious um do you feel that there
is a responsibility of for like researchers
to include or maybe even educate the mri scanner
techs uh as part of the research enterprise to
make sure that they understand the value of
uh getting uh you know relatively standardized
data even if they need to customize it a little
bit for different sizes of head you know what i
mean so i would say that at most places this is
um our our teams here at least at our hospitals
are so with the program they they at the
so we have a pretty virtuous cycle that the
research teams that develop and enhance our new
um like because we are a big research site for
for siemens and for other other manufacturers
where we are always we are evolving and advancing
the different kinds of technologies for later you
know for with a direct eye on clinical translation
so our our teams of researcher physicists
algorithm developers whatever are also very
closely parked in our clinical scanners helping
to support the training and that transition and
that translation our neuroradiologists are our
partners in all of this and everybody's pulling
towards the best possible data in the you know
in the best possible care of the patients and so
i think that there is uh i i think that if you
quietly took any one of our mr techs off in a
corner and had you know a kind and supportive
conversation with them you would come away
feeling like they really do know and they really
do care and they really are doing their best
that's that's super great i think it's really
important to keep those conversations going we
work a lot on on having like grand rounds and
having case conferences and doing things like
that there's a lot of in-servicing communication
is really important um and and i'm sure there's
outliers but it it you know it's a teams you
know all of this is a team sport you shared
with us uh some of the really interesting
uh databasing developments that you've done
there at mgh and i'm you're very familiar with
uh things that are large-scale neural imaging
data archives like the human connectome
project and various others of that spirit
where everybody you know from the centers around
the country are collecting all the same protocol
and exactly the same kind of scanners and and
all that so they're all very uniform um the
clinical data on the other hand like for example
i have very often interested in traumatic brain
injury data but getting that data there there's
very few places to go um to find it there are
a few but um i'm curious if you have any other um
databases that you are aware of and want to share
information about for our uh for our listeners so
um that you mean that are outside of the research
realm that might be like clinical databases
yeah absolutely yes so here's what i would say
i'm gonna guess that almost every major hospital
and academic health care system has in their packs
some pretty valuable traumatic brain images
already and that because that is i think
i'm gonna go out on a limb here i'm gonna
guess that uh brain imaging is one of the um
like for those little babies with hie i'm going
to guess that brain imaging is almost always done
and and so traumatic brain injury is a big
umbrella term like hie there's a lot of different
reasons why people have it car accidents
football you know getting shot in the head
huge variation in what that means and so we have
come a long way in developing imaging sequences
that are very useful for evaluating many of those
different sources of brain trauma and so there are
like susceptibility weighted imaging for example
comes to mind which is you know was not a very big
sequence you know when i started this baby
brains work but is now i think fairly bread
and butter on on most acquisitions that have that
as the clinical question i would venture to guess
if i were i'm not i'm kind of risk averse but i
think i would i would happily put money on a bet
that if you had colleagues at various big
medical centers who had neuroradiology
friends they could talk to and found out were
they doing these sequences for those patients
that you could put together a team of people and a
team of sites and find this data and work with it
and even though on the research side we harmonize
so explicitly for the every little detail of the
acquisition there is a layer of harmonization
that is happening across all scanners everywhere
because there you know there's siemens there's ge
they're philip there's there's only a few flavors
and each of them only have a few kinds and each of
them only have a few different software versions
and each of them and if they don't have like
our research licensing and special agreements
with the manufacturers they're using the bread
and butter sequences that are everywhere and
those tend to be quite good and so you probably
could find some really awesome opportunity there
that's great i was really i wrote down this
question before you kind of got to it there at the
end about uh sort of looking at sort of clinical
syndrome atlases and comparing sort of you know
patients that you might have against clinical
atlases to help clinicians make inferences about
where to look and it looks like and i wrote this
down thinking it wouldn't be cool to have a tool
that does that and then you went and showed
one so that's fantastic but i wanted to follow
up with that is that what role is there for data
scientists to help develop tools like that um what
are some low hanging things that could get people
excited about making those kind of tools i don't
know what makes this specific to a data scientist
i i mean yes we should all be doing this like com
so i i suppose a data so
data scientist is a new term for me because
everybody i know i consider a data scientist
so when you ask me that question in that way can
you give me a little bit more guard rails about
what your what kind of answer you want because
yes if you have access to data with you know
admiral you know a cohort with some abnormalities
that are quantitative that you can find then
there are tools to start working with that so what
do you what are you asking me certainly well i
usually like to think of data science as much more
broad than machine learning for example to say
that somebody who does machine learning as a data
scientist is sort of you know it's neither here
nor there really because of course they do but on
the other hand if you wanted to say apply machine
learning techniques and develop tools around that
um what else might they need to know in order to
get started doing that so so if you're working
in this particular little niche domain kind of
thing and you wanted to build those bridges things
that help a lot are being facile with working in
the field of clinical informatics so being able
to know and understand what are the warts and
whistles in working with ehr data so missingness
and sparsity and like when absence of information
doesn't mean that something's not there i mean you
it takes it's a whole mindset to know how to do
uh data science on electronic healthcare record
data so if you're and a lot of this work is best
served when you have a combination of the medical
imaging and the detailed clinical information
so for example with hie work while we none of
that data that we needed for doing our outcome
measures or to do some of the you know next
layers of work that we'll do where we look at
factors that influence outcome or more details
of care decisions all of that was gathered by
going through the clinical records and pulling
it out mining it out um you wouldn't be able
to get anywhere near as much meaning out of
those atlases the atlas application to those
cases that have problems without knowing those
clinical contexts the clinical context is
really really important for interpreting results
and so data scientists who can have enough
biomedical knowledge to comfortably you know
maneuver around in that space and interpret and
understand what's there or at least to be able to
ask all the good questions so that they have their
domain expert to you know to support them in that
way is really important um i think on the medical
imaging physics side understanding how variations
you have to know which data you can merge in which
you can't and so um for example with that the
tool i was showing with jojenio where he was
doing that post-processing for being able to take
the the thicker clinical slices and then um turn
them into isotropic voxels that would run through
freesurfer you have to know which you know things
like you can't use a post-contrast scan because
contrast introduces uh a change in the contrast
properties of all the tissue and so the algorithm
is completely different than in pre-contrast scans
you have to understand that the the way that the
free surfer works on that data the the anything
that it would output in terms of like a cortical
thickness measure is very suspect it's not really
trustworthy the way i say a hippocampal volume
could be and there's an interaction between
knowing the mr physics and the how the image
is generated and made and the properties of
the scan and then how those algorithms run and
so there are there's great it's really good to
do this in teams where because it takes a lot of
different people to know all the different parts
i think that's an important part is that uh
all of this is one of the reasons i enjoy this
is because it is a team sport and it really does
take a a collection of people with different and
interlocking skills to be able to deal with
the type of data the amount of data and all
the nuances you just described so absolutely
well uh dr gollub let me thank you so much for
joining us today and sharing your amazing work
um i really appreciate it thank you once again
and uh to all of our people who've been
listening in today thank you so much
everyone enjoy your weekend and we'll see you
next week thank you again randy my pleasure bye